thanks for joining us tonight at 11
o'clock I'm Sasha Loftis we start with
breaking news Metro Police say they are
investigating a murder-suicide in the
North Valley officers tell us both
bodies were found near Ann and North 5th
Street this afternoon that's why we find
Madison Kimbrough live with the latest
Madison
this happening just before 4 pm this
afternoon take a look behind me as you
can see Metro is still on scene still a
very active scene here right off of
Hammer Lane it's blocked off neighbors
sharing with me just how chaotic of an
afternoon it's been here
there was a person in the area that
heard gunshots but didn't think much of
it thought it was something else that
was going on in the area and then later
found out about the incident here at
work that incident being a being of
suicide located on East Hammer Lane near
5th Street and Ann Road just before 4 pm
Saturday two bodies were found lying
outside on the ground of a person's home
those bodies a woman and man said to be
in their 40s lying their dead with
gunshot wounds and according to Metro
Police it appears to be a domestic
dispute gone wrong the male and female
were both married and they both recently
separated in their relationship while
it's still unclear who shot Who police
say the two were found lying outside of
the man's home neighbors sharing the
crime in their neighborhood has become a
constant it's honestly disappointing how
you feel like you're supposed to feel
safe in your home but even late at night
you can't even do that and for many the
sound of gunshots nearby is nothing new
it's crazy in the middle of the night
you'll be sleeping and all you hear is
like going after gunshot going off like
we've counted them actually
Metro Police stating that there were no
other injuries reported and that the
couple's families have been notified
reporting live Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now